[Music]
good morning done it's Tuesday May 15th
one of the nerdfighters told me to try
that it was amazing congratulations
I'll buy in a house I know that it's not
final but they accepted your offer now
you have to go through all the horrible
process of actually buying a house
that's very exciting congratulations I
can't wait to visit it into you in
Indianapolis Indiana does everybody know
that you grew up in India plus Indiana
that you live there until you were like
three because I don't feel like you've
mentioned that but I think it's kind of
strange I mean of all the places in the
world to return to after living in
Alabama and Chicago and New York always
saying that you were going to go back to
Alabama now you're going back to where
you came from Indianapolis a place I'm
pretty sure you hated you were three but
I think you hated it under more
important matters evil baby orphanage I
really think there's only one option we
have to do this and I believe that we
must officially ask permission of the
nerdfighters Tobruk who conceived this
idea and all the other nerdfighters that
have been putting their brains to the
task can John and I run with us can we
try and do something with the evil baby
orphanage idea I mean I'm not saying
that that's gonna be a book out by Hank
and John Green called evil baby
orphanage but I think it's pretty
fertile ground for a story telling as
I'm asking permission nicely this time
next time won't be so nice I'll be
groveling at your feet begging and
pleading and kissing you on parts and
donating money to your favorite
charities because you're amazing and
it's a hilarious idea and we like it and
we want to work on it and let us know if
that's okay with you and that's for
Wikipedia I'm on Wikipedia oh my god I
feel so important I type in my name and
there I am and telling people about
stuff that I do there's been a little
bit of conversation in the comments
about Wikipedia as a source of
information there's obviously different
ways to use Wikipedia it's huge it's
great it has a lot of amazing
information but at the same time
sometimes it's vandalized things go
wrong for example I once went to Russell
Crowe's page please don't ask me why and
the first line about Russell Crowe read
as follows
Russell IRA Crowe is an Academy Award
winning New Zealand Australian actor and
is a gay so obviously there are laws in
the idea
of Wikipedia anybody can edit you don't
even have to sign up you could just
write whatever you want but I was able
to click Edit and I removed is a gay and
now people looking for information on
Russell Crowe will be completely happy
with what they find I actually really
believe in the idea of Wikipedia and I
am thrilled to be there among the
million other articles about important
and unimportant things and beyond there
is another amazing excellent gift that
you and the nerdfighters have given me
thank you all so much I'll see you
tomorrow